الا بعد خطوات من موقع التفجير الدامي
الذي قتل فيه قبل نحو شهر اكثر من 120
شخصا واصابه اكثر من 300 اخرين يتابع
هؤلاء صوماليون مباريات كاس العالم في قطر
لم يمنعهم الخوف من التفجيرات من الاهتمام
بالحدث العالمي في رساله اتحاد تاكد انهم
جزء من هذا العالم مهما كانت الظروف
بشكل دائم وساشاهدها حتى النهايه ونتمنى
انه هي المتابعه بسلام ويرى كثير من هؤلاء
ان مشاهده كاس العالم بشكل جماهير في
مقرشه تدور املي لافته لحد ذاته والدليل
على ان الوضع الامنيه في التحصننا وان
كانت امنياتهم تتجاوز مشكله الامن
قبل سنوات
في هذه الاماكن ومتابعه كاس العالم بشكل
جماعي الحمد لله الان اتابع المونديال مع
الجماهير وامنوا ان يكون منتخب بلادي يوم
ما من المتاهلين لكاس العالم
هذه المتابعه الجماعيه دليل على التحسن
الامني الذي تشهده مدينه مقديشو والتطور
الذي تشهده البلاد بشكل عام ونتطلع الى ان
نكون جزءا من هذه المسابقه الدوليه
المستقبلانا
تجذبهم الساحره المستديره هربا من هموم
العنف المتجدد احيانا في مقديشو فرجه
طبقهم في تواصل مع العالم على مدى شهر
واملهم الا يحدث ما يعكر الصف ومدعته من
هذه عبد الرحمن البخاري العربي